let's go to our next caller from the
four for three area code who's calling
today from four four three Lando from
Baltimore hey Lando hey uh so I'm I'm a
little confused
going into this Senate trial regarding
impeachment and I was hoping you might
have a little more info since I had
trouble exactly googling it so I'm
hearing that Mitch McConnell and Trump
are arguing about how to proceed with
the trial and what I'm hearing is that
Trump wants to extend it as long as
possible
and Mitch McConnell wants to get it over
with as soon as possible not sure of a
source on that but basically my question
is it does Trump have the power to do
that and what are you expecting out of
this impeachment trial beyond just what
we've already seen in the house
obviously Republicans are going to be
how they are and Democrats going to be
how they are weak and Republicans are
probably going to be very aggressive but
I'm just curious what your expectations
are and and how that's going to play out
where Trump tries to extend it does he
have the power to do so as the person
under you know impeachment I bet no
Trump does not have the power to decide
how long the trial will be now the thing
is Mitch McConnell listens to Trump on a
lot of things so if Trump says to Mitch
McConnell I think it would be
politically better for me if this thing
goes on and on and on then Mitch
McConnell might acquiesce to that and
and say or maybe gleefully would just go
along with it and say yeah we're gonna
make this thing really long let's let's
do it but no Trump does not have the
power to decide how long an impeachment
in the Senate that is filed by the house
is going to be now as far as what the
impact would be this is the question
I've said before I don't see any path to
the to a conviction in the Senate there
are 47 Democrats 45 plus two
independents you need 67 to vote to
convict where are you getting 20
Republican votes I don't see it so
therefore it becomes just a PR
calculation who benefits from a longer
versus a shorter trial
what can Democrats do in the trial
versus Republicans to help their cause
in 2020 and to hurt or help Donald Trump
in 2020 in his reelection
that it's going to be a circus in that
sense and I what we're still waiting to
hear what the parameters are going to be
in the timing and the scheduling yeah
sure so just in your try to consider and
they have other colors but just in your
opinion what is the potential longest
that Mitch can drag it out if that's
what he is directed I don't know legally
what we can do I don't know legally what
you can do I think it would be very hard
to justify it lasting more than a month
and my understanding is that right that
initially the Senate is keeping their
January calendar clear to account for
the possibility of the trial I don't
know of any way that it was longer than
a month and I would assume it's a couple
weeks thank you okay cool thanks so much
subscriber longtime listener appreciate
your on biased opinion hope you have
some happy holidays and thanks for
taking my call thank you so much
appreciate it and great to hear from you